usual launch angles doncic  the closeout by crowder here's vinnie  smith  and he's gonna call for the athletic  trainer they're gonna have to take a  foul here but maybe too late  [Applause]  finney smith  knocks down the three  it just goes under the screen payne now  picks up luca  luca playing with his food out there  over to finney smith  this ball takes it personally when you  think he can be posted up  kick out to the corner finney smith  five points and six times luca  sprays it out to finny smith again from  deep and again knocks it home  another offensive rebound  vinny smith got it  hooker on the drive  had it blocked by cleveland  [Applause]  vinnie smith one more to bullock  then he smith for three  for finney smith booker with a miss  ayden had it knocked away brunson back  the other way for dallas  he checked finney smith  [Applause]  success is never owned it is rented and  rent is due every single day and right  now vinnie smith is paying the rent